i
oh
some
uh
or some na
uh so
yeah that was the freedom theme as
performed acoustically by russell kabir cognitive science
ph d and associate professor professor at
hiroshima university are always drunk i'm so
i shall actually profile
news sure the proof age of of
ah that's my friend and he heard
me say that i owe your friend
yeah yeah yeah might be crushed by
mike's friend mike sprenger nepotism here he
heard me say that i wanted an
acoustic cover of three of them and
he delivered and he wasn't the only
one but we will hear more of
these my good friend
he's also the only one to do
it in japanese when he didn't dance
he did so apparently each one of
the versions that he said means ah
sort of version of three or three
people or so i could get more
information on that later no thank you
oh good alright wow dick hole scott
you are being a bit of a
decal you mean that hole in
a dick where
peto
any other why and i don't even
like to talk huh yeah
three things sorry
welcome to three adam my name is
lauren lucas mine my name is erin
lucas and the coincidentally my name is
paula tomkins it's just a coincidence
that's how i three or four loop
kiddos that was remember tim allen he
would make the noise and people thought
it was great man was it probably
stand-up yeah we're standards lower or where
it was or just not only entertainment
that anyone could see no one did
noises
before here's what here's what's interesting about
that to me now i loved that
show but i was a child now
as they were both made for adults
i mean when you became billy when
you became a man you put away
childish things right oh yeah and rap
i think that for some reason wrap
the shrimp
put on your rap rap
rep coop so the idea is that
day
it was made for families and so
it had to be in this middle
place where it could appeal to absolutely
everybody um without fear of repercussions paul
you're out of focus but right now
by the way when i look at
me honey you who you tell it
you're like gorda holiday season in my
rye
right ah boy but you know it
is the ah we just spent christmas
together the three of us woke up
in our bed and put on our
little took off our nightcaps and yeah
and without our daniel we got a
candle stubs and we went downstairs and
guess who had visited us ah no
not you the audience
oh okay guess i missed the space
leave it leave spent livable again sorry
guess who had visited us huh you
guys are shouting too loud but you're
right i heard a few of you
say santa why heard one person say
sinter klaas i heard one person say
kris kringle
no one said yo apoyo oh god
that was from ah last friday's scott
hasn't seen a little in joke for
that um why he was ah the
santa klaus well it's also from life
and something that everyone knows everyone knows
it
do how many people do you say
grew up watching that movie in nineteen
ninety four they were like kids or
whatever and they have no idea what
fuckin toyota is yeah this number who
knows you are a child i don't
know you don't know what do you
still not know i will give you
three guesses
well i actually can quote it but
i don't know what i'm quoting or
what i'm talking yeah it's quite a
quote
but isn't it from something funny it's
from santa claus i gotta get away
from that no no it's not that's
that isn't in itself a reference i'm
going to give you lauren three guesses
as to what toyako is ok well
what do mean is what is it
a reference or is you bill clinton
wait a minute are you bill clinton
i did not inhale that woman ah
i've always looked at you being like
there's something funny about her she bill
clinton yeah you playing that saxophone he
figured it out and or bds in
my bds phone
folks wasn't it was he waited was
he a boxer guy or was he
a brief sigh i can't remember but
i remember that question being i remember
it being such a important question to
know what oh hilarious that someone on
mtv like asked him that and then
i don't remember the answer at all
about we could find out if we
want to that's back before we knew
that the fate of the world was
in terrible hands
anyways to bajo so um ok you
look it up i did not i
didn't i was adding these christmas lights
because you get three guesses and wait
and how do we work this do
we say warm or cold or what
do we do yeah start well it's
three it's three guesses yes no i'll
give you a feel for my first
run i'll move towards the second le
corps corps okay is there
now i have okay as an snl
reference no but somewhat warm somewhat warm
okay hold on is it a late
show of some sort reference you man
you're not gonna get it if you
waste if you get get incrementally closer
but yeah okay older okay i'm warmer
though
i say colder
well can i have ten guesses yeah
go we gotta give
i had to do is ask you
can have twenty you're twenty
and okay so it's a way to
have we doing to yeah two shows
this is basically ten questions as well
we're going okay yes and i was
warm but then a late show was
colder than us and l yeah i
think so yeah i think scott does
too i i turn him around
i turned him around
hey was the original thing from a
television thing yes it was from a
television thing that's important yeah it is
is it from a movie no just
said it was from a television what
are you okay cause establish and thing
yes it's from a movie
yes the santa claus you were saying
like it could have been on tv
no i wouldn't i wouldn't count movies
that run on tv okay
ah hold on for you have six
questions left okay did it have to
do it but damn i wish i
had taken a lot of those and
asked different stuff um does it have
to do with um and ah
ah all done
this is not one of my questions
is helpful to okay yes about tv
shows yeah okay
is it from the seventy s no
no it's from the eighties now colder
colder from the sixty s ye yeah
i would i would give her sixty
s wouldn't you yes sure yeah i
would yeah is it from a variety
show yeah yes that's a question is
it from carol burnett who know oh
if only you knew that that was
a seventy show no shit yeah i
didn't know that um sixties you have
one more question you asked laughing no
wow you're out of your out but
you could ask for five more yep
yeah sure
it's a variety show from the sixties
not laughing that's kinda the only thing
i can really think of i don't
really know other ones but i'm gonna
keep going um i don't really know
any so it's kind of hard we
even ask a question to be honest
yeah can remember it's not it's not
an obscure one no it's very famous
yes
give me a hint okay i'll give
you one very famous variety show from
the sixty so i'll give you i'll
give you wing it
i'll give you one word in it'll
if if you know what it is
this will tell you if you don't
it won't shoe
as in i'll give you this full
sentence okay you should have asked me
can use it in a sentence can
you use in a sentence we have
a really big shoe
we have doing huge a date
i almost feel like if you don't
get toyo you're also not going to
get that but she she just said
it she just like said the reference
we've yes she did didn't help
like i know in my memory palace
somewhere oh go there okay yeah you
just go there and and figure it
out i thought you were there the
whole time i'm trying to be there
okay you have six more questions johnny
carson no no but i know i
already knew that did you um okay
it wasn't late
show oh that's true that's true okay
can i
give you some other air now at
seventy s can i give you another
word yeah mop
mop
bob scott if you're everywhere i think
you're headed a matter you want i'll
give you one more word okay tops
shoe mop tops
don't allow it since issue mata ojas
from shoe mop tops mop tops um
um the beatles
what right make you think of
the monk dixie's varane mushy yes you're
right it was the mummy's fair fairy
is it really oh no it was
not the monkeys the fun we have
it like when she gets the actual
show she doesn't even know what it
is what does the deals make me
think of yeah sixty s variety show
and think of the beatles
alright do you do any of those
like images of the beatles in the
sixties with like people screaming and then
playing on tv like what does that
make you think of
tv yeah yeah good okay
getting closer yay
did you see bye bye birdie the
musical bye bye birdie
only when a high school did it
accounts
ah i don't know okay okay have
a cup of this how about this
a famous horse but with bread without
the honorific ed
ed homeland i know this
i do know this okay now think
of a famous pilot
and what he would drive around what
he would drive around yes sullivan you
said as yeah yes sullivan yes yeah
okay so that's what it was no
it was from nowhere defensive
you only get thirty more questions to
determine what what did yeah does it
was it a waiter that was like
don't bajo no
that's something the waiter would say and
by the way are there a lot
of waiters on television shows like delivering
sketch and sketch oh i see i
thought you meant like just delivering apps
during the show i certainly didn't mean
that over you back in the golden
age of television yes that's what they
would do they would bring hot apps
around to the artist tell me that
context okay vizio was a little mouse
puppet wow and he had a little
italian accent i'm use very adorable
it was like whoa trabajo
q yeah oh so-called it all i
guess it was his own name wow
i'm looking at embracing that's not true
he could say any other name he's
really adorable
so this is a fun game so
that was a fun game so don't
do the three-tier now yeah that was
a three-term listen to a preacher yeah
so that's a lot of fun laura
and a lot of them figured out
what toyo is so now you whenever
you say oh yeah so that's a
lot of fun okay
i just want to reiterate that this
is a blast and when i figured
it out you'll eat it
now until it let us guess something
we don't know okay yes there's gotta
be something okay although i can't think
of anything because i don't know it
mimi they're all so should i come
up with like a ref like a
random thing like that and have to
get something you know the we don't
know okay
i mean i'll just try the first
thing came to mind you might know
it
what is this from
rap star
say again did you say r e
p rap atar rat atar r e
p t a r
reptile reptile okay neither of us know
this this is good from perkins upfront
okay i guess first yeah and you
get five questions each is it from
a sitcom no oh is it from
a movie that was on tv a
few times no well technically probably yes
but that's not where it's not real
the word originates is it from a
movie based on a sitcom no is
it from a sitcom based on a
different sitcom know what you're wasting your
question why
can i have ten more questions yeah
okay good can i have eleven more
because i'm stupid is it from a
commercial no
is it was there ever a commercial
for the thing that it was on
yes great what way i can follow
that
was it a cartoon was a cartoon
yes was it a saturday morning cartoon
um not in the traditional sense
ooh no in the traditional sense
is it from a cartoon where a
boy had a head shaped like a
football yes
is it from hey arnold no
how many cartoons or their voice was
like football shaped heads actually is a
head that's shaped like a football i
mean in charlie brown they used to
draw football laces on his head right
that's right yeah so it's probably not
what i'm cruel which which which by
the way that
tacitly is saying that he is bald
and not just that he has a
short haircut i thought they were always
kinda ever thought he has a short
haircut he has one hair no i
think that
i think that was supposed to be
the official thing i feel like i
remember researching lakes like he's he's like
i thought they were all three years
old essentially and he just hasn't had
hearing your trailers old you know i
don't like about charlie brown when people
do live charlie brown and they also
have a bald head for charlie it's
like we don't need it's weird we
don't need the bald head
just had just just have yourself a
short haircut we don't need the ball
head guy we donate um all hey
just put on the sweater and shut
up and don't talk that famous sweater
is the ah lauren is the football
head is it ah vertical or horizontal
horizontal but again
n don't think i don't you should
focus on that because i don't think
it's going to help you i don't
think all i can think about
why don't they make footballs in the
shape of heads that's a really good
question another soccer balls now that's that's
like in the shape of a globe
your head thinks oh i don't know
if anyone's ever told you that my
head is what a perfect circle yeah
thank you you know that right
it's not a sphere it's just a
circle is a two dimensional flat yeah
it's just a flat circle like talk
time hello
we've done it we should end the
episode right now yeah goodbye everybody come
on guys it's our first fifty minute
episode come on now our next episode
begins now you can guess it all
right is it the karate kid no
it's a cartoon yeah that was whatever
did just this cartoon depict does this
cartoon depict rats who hang around on
rugs yeah yes ah tar was the
serial slash scary godzilla type figure slash
chocolate bar characters slash many things rep
tar bars they fought against him no
i mean
in their minds i guess if i'm
remembering any of that correctly oh did
they have like fantasy adventures with repertoire
i don't know you would see rupture
but i remember what the context was
like i do with the memes especially
the horny one yeah you have a
lot going on with that one
if i have a lot of fan
fiction that i wrote about me and
the green m and m so how
do you guys do it it's filthy
do you have to like chomp a
whole
can you wait today already send the
shoe
but did already send this to you
it's exactly what happens that's exactly what
happens if you want to be in
a boxing match with any cartoon character
and it wasn't someone that you could
just like obliterate like a green eminem
or whatever you could just eat him
or whatever like it had to be
pretty evenly matched who would it be
first of all i wouldn't even eat
the green eminem in a in a
boxing match i would just pummel liquor
i would just kill and i would
absolutely destroy the green eminem when they
need it but i would say i
in it to make an interesting i
would want it to be popeye but
he doesn't have access to spinach how
do how does he not have access
to it do they
to lock it away it's a rule
yes it's a rule like you can't
bring you can't bring food and i'm
assuming popeye popeye isn't following rules out
there he's in the navy
he's sworn to follow rules he might
he might risk a dishonorable discharge to
eat that spinach like you need to
actually physically keep it away from him
is what i'm saying like there needs
to be some sort of safe you
know that's what the referee is for
the referees there just to protect the
safe or to put it in the
safe yeah
free is the only one who has
an comedy
there's before the matches big ceremony right
where he puts two cans of spinach
in the safe so i have access
to one too if i can if
i can crack the code that's not
gonna do anything for you why didn't
nobody how do you know nobody ever
tried it no one earns it no
one ever like lava heat hadn't it
been just so discussing oh can you
fucking imagine he's gonna barf
well especially when he's when he's squeezes
it and flies up in the air
and he just opens his mouth and
lips is oh just a barrage of
spinach i'm fine sailor man i live
in a garbage can what does that
that's right no that was it that
was the end i see you next
week don't have a moat i go
i'm penny wise's best friend
pennywise through i wouldn't get along yeah
there's oh sky they have a similar
point of view i think what's their
want to have a lot in common
i'm the ground up
what are their similarities
what is the similarities in their worldview
they're both incredibly handsome they both have
names that starts with p yeah oh
shit and insee that
anyway we're calling it the clown
hey it's a clown i saw somebody
i know i know somebody's i saw
somebody referred to pennywise as if the
clown on
tweet what i really mean you have
they were not trying to be funny
before i saw the new it i
did refer to him as it of
course builded okay if you had to
be the protagonist in any stephen king
novel or movie wait a minute or
which one about them in particular this
question yeah i've always
i'm saying how many questions to keep
are we no no don't put a
part to i got to do part
one so to you yes that's real
if i were going to fight a
cartoon character my first thought was to
think of someone who is physically like
me so my first person that came
to mind and you might not know
this reference pepper ran
i don't i've heard another man but
i don't know what she looks like
another easy cartoon character she's a seventh
grader
okay i know what they look like
each and everyone
they all look like right google or
google or
i arrived i it popped in my
head i would pick pepe le pew
but then i you know because he
gets so horny that it would be
like you'd get structured by someone in
the audience you know why would you
ever want to fight a big skunk
i know that seems my video we
have a little skunk who we see
it on the cameras he like goes
through are ya
hard and then goes underneath the the
gate all the time and we're like
there's that little guy again sure i've
told the story of when my house
got sprayed by thousand sixth grade i
don't remember i remember you mentioning that
yes i can't tell it again it's
very long but it involved me going
to school reeking of skunk eve
no i didn't oh i don't remember
that part it took over the entire
house we had to be pumping it
out with these machines and we had
to throw out a bunch of clothes
that were in the hopefully not those
terminator machines boy they're gonna take over
the world ah no it wasn't that
it was some sort of reverse fan
situation but i
i am not a terminator
the ah frank fell into our window
well and got trapped than the guy
the animal control came and she's like
what's my one move this all i
know how to do i can't get
out of here so here goes well
in the animal control guy shot him
and miss now with like a tranquilizer
thing and missed him then he sprayed
again many did it
again think sprayed on his way out
now now just out of anger yeah
because he knew that he was shot
out anyway so it was pretty traumatizing
i can learn i smell a skunk
i get really scared and when i
see a skunk i feel nervous like
okay now everything i have is gonna
smell it was so i would just
school my backpack wreaked so much and
i remember walking into
lunch and like everyone's crowded together and
was like oh this was like skunk
and here i was like ah it's
me it's me oh you you owned
up to it though no i didn't
say it i just oh you're just
in your mind oh okay yeah why
don't you just pretend that you like
smoked out in your car i didn't
even know about that yet oh shit
so yeah i reek of weed that's
gone it's weed i'm filling
arrest me principle
principles arrest should principles be allowed to
arrest children um we'll take your calls
when we come back
yeah
you know absolutely not they do that
you know well for how long these
videos know there's really fucked up things
that are happening where the police come
to school i could get in trouble
and they arrest them and like nine
or something there's like the horrible things
that have happened like that that's so
easy it's been it's like they're arresting
six year olds and stuff like that
yeah it's like what what could you
possibly be thinking
as a grown adult doing that makes
knife saying sister traumatizing that all nine
year olds should be arrested and then
we just let the good ones free
c o who were bad kids scott
yeah who are the good ones scott
the ones that prove you know that
they're well like median children yeah exactly
bd
you're so you're like they have to
perform three acts of obedience every day
and if they stand on top yes
santa cop yeah santa cop who made
you santa cop that's one of the
key lines for children free yeah scott
what cartoon character would you fight well
i said pepe le pew and it's
like you immediately started skunks
oh i forgot yeah i did yeah
i stand by it
well you said you first were thinking
of pepe le pew but then did
you have another one in your little
mind
in your tiny mind i mean tasmanian
devils hilarious so that would be so
fun fucking you have a death wish
bro
you will show and by that you
know what why was that why was
looney tunes so cool to everyone for
a second where like everyone had looney
tunes like tabs jacket and like stuff
like that that's i don't know weird
is that would lead to space jam
or did space jam lead to that
i think is so
space jam led to that you know
because i personally just recently yeah just
yeah space jam but like always you
won't
what was your what oh um was
gonna say hello i'm gonna look at
one space jam came out look at
what makes champagne ninety nine things you
know i think this is already happening
at this point i will tell you
i remember seeing well no i feel
like it was happening maybe that was
when it started happening yeah i remember
seeing a jean jacket with a picture
of tweety bird on the back
and he's looking fuckin pissed right yeah
he's got his little arms folded he's
got an expression on his face like
you don't want to cross twee bird
and underneath it said and your point
is
good shit good i would wear that
shit i want that we all
looney tunes why aren't you sponsoring us
here on three adam yeah looney tunes
get on the crocs train yeah this
is pretty good there's a lot of
looney tunes wearing crocs q imagine tweety
burden croc oh it would be so
red lodge can you imagine shoe charms
that some shibori and crocs is great
because his feet are almost cry
ox his feet are crocs yeah yeah
you just need to poke holes in
his feet fear almost oh don't do
that i think i'll go even further
tweety bird's head is like a crock
to you know what i think i
think his butt belly and arms are
like cross
i think t-birds little beak is like
two crocs
dude dudas okay aid of crocs from
the judaism on aid of crop like
seven crocs ah and human crocs is
a tweety bird and but i think
if you arranged seven crocs in the
the right order you it would look
like tweety bird wouldn't it um i
wanna see some crock art now i
want our list
owners to make little sculptures out of
how however many crocs you have in
the house put them all together try
to make a tweety bird okay i
do i was gonna say let's not
embarrass our listeners by making them do
that and then i thought nah i
want to see that i do want
to see it i want to see
seven crowds or less yeah you can't
use more than seven no
seven is the kid
take it to the limit you have
only seven wow one more tweety
yeah just hold on just for that
sure looks like a whole lot waddled
over to li t
hello everyone was like oh
sweetie
yeah i don't know if i told
you guys the story there was a
ah a nerd
we both take you on my nighttime
story already yeah wait all of your
other stories have taken place during the
day every other story ever told you
took place during the day like yes
so now it puts it sheds a
whole new light daylight on a lot
of those stories okay yeah because a
lot of you are picturing happening at
night but no broad daylight wow they'll
happen
noon every story i've ever told you
has happened at noon so this is
your first nighttime story this is exciting
this is my one and only nighttime
story oh this is the only one
you have okay no sunday this is
the only time know so far i
mean look life is long who knows
but ah so far this is the
one thing that's of interest that's happened
to me at night what's weird is
you're mainly awake at night and you
only
are awake for one hour of daylight
you were telling i know but everybody
else is asleep oh okay so every
happens you and that one hour you
stay up everything happens in the one
hour i stay up all night long
i'm awake ah let's see i'm awake
from eleven fifty nine to one oh
one pm and then i i'm asleep
the rest of the time
right okay yeah i know is that
right no yeah i still don't know
you describe completely wrong because to be
a stamp all morning i say okay
so i have so most of my
stories happen in the daytime but i
do stay up all night
other than the fact that half the
night you're asleep yeah i'm exhausted
my circadian rhythms were all iraq rock
my zucchini ranger i ride a wreck
tell your time story pool i was
recording well here the nineteen li pali
tell you nine i'm still replete to
be one right i was recording with
supergirl and a bunch of other people
were doing this big fun project and
like we
while everyone is getting giddy and it's
really having fun
and earlier in the in the evening
somehow there was talk of ah coney
twenty twelve this may have been when
it happened in twenty three yeah um
not really sure joseph kony not a
great guy and i guess twenty twelve
what happens a little puppet from the
absolve in show
oh my god what are you twenty
twelve and my name is coney twenty
twelve
and so i'm awaiting it it had
been a reference earlier in the evening
and then at the end of the
night
i can't remember who it was they
came up with like the perfect punchline
that wrapped up the whole like the
the perfect button on the whole thing
everyone was laughing and i have this
weird thought of my head and i
knew what i was doing
but it still
as everyone is laughing like one second
and everyone's laughter at this thing that
was perfect i said why oh it
and everyone stopped and i said coney
twenty twelve and then a couple people
felt bad and laughed and i was
like oh nah wasn't the in my
mind
the point was
this thing that was just said was
perfect what i'm saying is lame and
that was funny to me i guess
but i didn't know one could get
that at that oh everybody was like
oh no he really thought that was
gonna be even funny oh my god
that tells me it was mortifying isn't
like like it's always the worst i
mean it happens all the time when
you're a funny person
in that you will say things that
aren't funny like just thank you
i mean but it's just it's a
natural part of being funny that you're
gonna have some clunkers for sure but
it's the worst feeling in the world
i think like when you like things
so it's gonna be funny and then
it's not i would rather bomb on
stage than have a joke knock over
in front of people in life
what's what's worse is when you say
something really funny and your two friends
shit on you and say it's not
funny but it actually is funny ca
you say something funny that doesn't happen
to me i think you guys are
always very generous with your laughter
oh my god i am i'd yeah
totally i think we're silly guys yea
silly so silly oh hey wait so
when is this episode coming o j
the thursday after christmas
um well can we just admit that
we're recording before christmas
yeah no oh god
i will never admit it somebody who
i'm talking to will never admit it
young why would you out of me
why do you want to admit that
because i wanna ask if you're excited
for christmas
it seems more like it off my
calm so sure this is pretty private
okay all but people like to hear
us talk of like from it's the
first christmas
ever well no no my in tons
i don't remember a single one
i was just gonna say that i
haven't got an eighty two years zero
you don't remember when the angel gladwell
came way to my weight room with
my boys with frankenstein oh my god
wait yeah i had a solo and
um seventh grade choir chorus and it
was it was
i distinctly remember walking up to the
microphone to do this okay it's not
even it's not even particularly funny or
anything just it's funny that i did
this i was just little dork but
i was
brother brother
ah have you heard the news is
from the angel gabriel every word is
true the lord said down
it's a help to didn't live as
one
that's nice that's pretty adorable
um let me ask you this oh
my god i look i was raised
with religion i went to catholic school
and all that blah blah blah church
every sunday of course i would go
to midnight mass i loved it but
what i don't remember is i don't
did they did the angel gabe
ariel give everybody the whole story like
hey god has sent his only son
to redeem everybody by dying a grisly
death if you think i know the
answer to that i'm just literally out
the extent of my knowledge is what
was saying what was the gabriel story
again who did he
yeah i sang everything i know until
i got a buddy who did he
appear in front of like the shepherd
marry well for yeah i think the
e when you're talking about shepard's first
to marry and it was like guess
huh you have no choice in this
year right yeah boom got to write
then um ebro
he appeared to the shepherds and he
was like everybody fucking relax
a baby jesus is being born everything's
going to be good okay stop being
afraid of me i know i'm scary
to you
yeah so after nouns you name any
identity gabriel explained to marry that would
be a virgin birth caused by the
holy spirit on the slide servant mary
answered may your word to me be
fulfilled can you do this fucking imagine
left he does not appear in the
bible again at least by name oh
so here are some other some other
angel daniel
he appears to zechariah and then he
appears to marry and then he pieces
out wow and now he's fascinating to
me because when you really think about
it can you imagine like sending one
of your best friends to tell your
girlfriend that she's pregnant for from you
but in this scenario also your girlfriend
is your best friend who somebody has
never seen you right yeah so just
know if you're actually believe that you
exist but but the but gabriel didn't
impregnate her i know that's what my
point is you sent your friend to
go like oh hey by the way
oh or he was there to enunciate
it
send your best friend to tell your
girl or a girl you're interested in
that your girl you're gonna get pregnant
by tell your crush that god is
going to impregnate
i told my crush
hey can you pass this note to
marry
i bet you someone's already done some
web series like that where it's like
let her teens having the bible happen
who i'm sorry did you say little
teens having the bible happen yeah dean's
abbey the bible of course a little
cheese having the bible happen little change
having the bible happen
bible in it
it
a balboni
guys we have to take a break
ok know more about the first christmas
when we come back
do you need to have a bible
in it
lane it
dave live on d do you remember
boy have you guys seen ah a
spy movie i have not the one
that is by burying her now whereas
i thought you meant any spy movie
they made a movie he's got a
single spy movie you've been having taylor
but never say i've watched but but
it's so funny i love the stuff
they do it's just so silly and
you know stephanie kane wrote and directed
and edited the whole thing wow that's
amazing yeah yeah yeah it's really it's
really funny it's extremely sill
early it's very much them and what
they do um but there's a character
in it that i think is inspired
by one of the mission impossible movies
had a bad guy intoned nine these
you alone and gay least it feels
me know email you're in trouble
i'm sorry what was that noise i
was opening up the movie
i wanted to see it it sounded
like you were doing an impression and
was doing two voices at the same
time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i was okay i do danger
now brazil a couple of years ago
and um one of the one of
the videos that i loved so much
he's made well
he has a couple of his web
series called the secret life of caleb
gallo though i really loved and he
also had er though the gay wondrous
life of kyoko i just mixed up
the secret life of the american teenager
the gay and wondrous life of slow
tab um yeah and you really put
that together quickly that we did this
week
oh dear dear for we referred to
it as slow tat yeah that's funny
but that was a good thing to
come from me of course but they
also made a really funny one called
i think it's called web series the
movie and it's really hilarious and i
even played it for my mom and
she thought it was great even your
mom well i just mean it's the
kind of thing that maybe if you
weren't like if you didn't know the
people you know i wasn't sure if
it would be
it would translate to like just a
random person watching it and she thought
it was one mom's agrees
so nice you consider your mom to
be a random person
she's so random my mom is so
random i'm almost sue soy random saw
you random so it's slightly random it's
a toy rant i'm speaking of australian
accents have you
ah what's it called
ah hold on i'll never forget it
a relay race no no around my
guess is yeah aretha franklin
ah love on the spectrum we talked
about this no i've heard it's great
furniture really weak yeah i've heard it's
great i don't think i want to
watch it why
reality i don't i don't like shows
like that to begin with and but
it's not what you you might sound
what you might think i don't think
it's mean i've heard it's not no
it's definitely it's just super yeah it's
super heartwarming and like the people on
it so it's for anyone who doesn't
know it's um the show is an
australian reality show about people on
the spectrum dating each other or dating
in the world and going on dates
and then they have like or they're
dating each other or they're dating in
the world exactly what to say to
power both on the show is what
i mean by that now you have
a choice you can either date each
other or you can date in the
world what's it gonna be anyway
these they help them with um like
a dating code she like she tells
themself to say or like how to
have a god i wish i had
one of those yeah you want a
really benefited you had a lot of
girlfriends scott still worked out it's true
you did okay maybe you should be
the dating coach scott oh here's the
real question yeah
tell me about rushing into marriage second
roommate oh yeah it really time room
may ram and nesbitt men's room
a yes zoom roommate reminiscence ruminate on
that
i guess we could if you were
gonna remember because i did not yeah
i didn't remember it at all paolo
when we when we last left off
roommate reminiscence you had broken up with
lyndon from linda linda linda lori
marie
and she workshops about that she worked
at ah the wicked witch of the
west
wound up all wound up close very
close that's about from the ground up
wow that high bout time what did
you call it wound wound tight no
all sound up
curious to know the wound wound is
standing in for another word oh wound
yeah god's wounds god's wound and it's
it's class gods wows and it sells
we sold windup to religious windup push
oh wow
wound to the clock wound and bounds
that's closer actually round the clock
whoa and
wound wound okay bound wout
wow well i want to say it
was ah wow
wow i feel like it was all
just tele doers what was it time
to go ten times it was the
last wound up there we go it
was yeah it was why is josh
telling us like you don't know paul
just just chant the last wound up
he's trying to help us cheat
okay i can see it too so
he just wanted it to be over
so you ah human i worked at
hats in the belfry you and you
break it off with her and you're
like baby we can be roommates no
more
i got to live i can't be
tied down like you're nineteen did she
stay so
did she stay in the apartment did
you stay in the yeah she stayed
in the apartment and you left you
i left i moved i think i
moved back home for a little bit
oh were you then i got an
apartment back down
no i was one who initiated the
breakup but you know which is ridiculous
um yeah i guess i guess i
was sad i was not i was
not bereft in that way um because
i was dumb
sometimes when i think back to stuff
like that that i did i'm like
so embarrassed oh it's mortifying yeah my
my entire life i wanna say before
the age of forty one is mortifying
so i haven't even had years not
growing until i'll be not mortified i
think you're doing okay lauren la yes
hey i love everything i've
ever done i think i ate well
that's obvious yeah you think you nail
every interaction i think that shows through
um and then and then i'm then
then i got an apartment i was
in an apartment with
oh boy oh boy oh boy i
had a bunch of roommates at the
same time at wo meaning they all
moved in at the same time we
all moved into this house together this
rowhouse well this won't happen here just
for everyone who plays this game now
we're gonna hear roommates too through whatever
you know with you yeah and
they were all in the person and
hear two through wherever you do we
do it by living space not by
the person although although right now yeah
you do it you do it by
chronologically meaning if you had three roommates
and then one moves out and another
one moves in that that one who
moves in that's your next one that
does
can count see you call that number
three yeah okay okay so what were
the first ones i moved into this
house with ah two people that i
knew and a stranger um it was
my old comedy partner rick ah his
my girlfriend and my friend jules and
all what was his fucking name i
think his name was mike todd todd
todd
todd rick and jules all worked as
carriage drivers um and i did not
i was the sole retail worker in
the house where did where would they
drive the carriages around is there a
certain part of philly that that is
is like yeah they would get there
yes there were i think there were
a few come
companies
and they would have different tours that
they would do and then they would
anywhere else for one of the companies
or they worked for one of the
companies and they would point out like
independence hall and you know blah blah
blah oh the little
did different historical places senator philadelphia has
a lot of them that it has
a liberty bell whoa oh yeah um
so yeah i mean you ll i
could count rushmore yeah the statue of
ah arlington cemetery yeah yeah it's the
birthplace of liberty and ah when i
wish
with ah gabe rez i made him
walk like thirty minutes to sweetgreen he's
like just some random
spotted it
he's like it's also phil philly also
for those places where you probably passed
a million places to eat on your
way to say it was no kobe
ah there was no covert fuck oh
aye that was one of my favorite
shows i've ever done was that show
with you guys
as in philly that was really fun
that was wild raised by tv live
and it was a blast so financial
shows yeah sorry you wouldn't have wanted
to come
you really wouldn't have scott and wasn't
what i wanted don't why there were
no comic books anyways
forget it
so we lived in this in this
house um which was not i remember
the houses was pretty good but we
were all nobody was really that responsible
so things would get shut off like
we had a phone um that we
all share that got shut off and
never turned back on again
i think our gas got turned off
so we couldn't cook and so when
your phone got turned off or you're
just like i don't have a phone
there's no way to reach me because
that work one hundred percent right yes
this is way before cell phones trying
to be like i'm going to go
to a payphone to call somebody
yeah although i i feel like you
just called people less spec them you
know like you made you sort of
made plans in person oh no i
i remember you always well i mean
unless you were hanging out with them
like at school paul i think you
made plans in person because you didn't
have a phone yeah
weird because i remember it like you
just made plans in person and not
on that phone that didn't work
remember i would write letters to people
to ask anything but i but i
later but a whole lot of second
this i just don't have a phone
not have a phone from that point
until yesterday like we've gotten
other times right today i only got
yesterday so like it's a razer phone
from two thousand ah oh yeah stir
day
only i loved them i had a
hot so major i was the shit
bitch i had the eyes of the
classic silver i loved it i love
so great well i had we should
do phone roundup i had oh yeah
sure
and my first i had a pager
that i had a singular around that's
going ahead but it was cool because
they could you could call the pager
and there was an operator who would
type the message to me would be
like a tax write but was always
fucked up then i had my cingular
wireless phone which is almost like an
egg shape it was so cool i
loved it i remember getting a couple
of text messages in my bedroom but
they were ten cents a piece i
couldn't get in to
told by texting too much that i
had the hot pink laser then i
got the blackberry pearl then i got
the we're doing the phone round right
now i'm just i'm already so excited
for already canned topper that i had
the iphone until now and i with
all the different iphones ever i had
first was the ah the like the
star tack it
was like a little black phone was
like this start out very small first
well phones mobile phone started out huge
then they got extremely small that might
have been they got really smart phones
again it was very exciting um then
i had um the blackberry pearl and
then love my guys from pirates of
the caribbean yeah
blackberry hey it's haunted it's wonderful
and then i got the iphone wow
and it's been great ever since we
know what i really really want is
that i really want that samsung phone
that has a screen and folds and
half the whole screen folds in half
yes these ridiculous to me i want
that but i don't want to be
green on the text chain and ruin
it for everyone
i thought they'd just fix that i
don't know oh i don't think so
no no they certainly haven't i have
a few key people in my life
or green they're relevant
well let's see i had a phone
and i don't remember what it was
and then ah well i'm sorry i
also had a nokia phone in there
somewhere because i remember oh hey we
were playing snake well i think i
must have been what i had a
no-gi yeah had the nokia ringtone on
my iphone for years as a joke
but a joke yeah it's pretty funny
oh shit
so lauren made the joke and then
scott heightened it this is what the
pros do we're back to roommate rhonda
i mean i can't i can't hear
on this phones i don't have time
i'm saying okay and then i then
i had other phones oh okay let's
talk about either us shot okay scott
had fun with nude ladies
on them that's why it doesn't want
to talk about i don't know yeah
and yeah snake game make into a
nude lady then you would a nude
key it took hours
but it was worth it and it
was all just a trace in his
memory of how he made a receipt
roy burned into the screen yeah i
remember that i would get emails on
that nokia and in order to type
them out you had to press like
each but yeah i'd like to do
ie or fifteen yeah ah because love
t nine i was showing nine i
was sure the superfan have that go
away what do you guys feel about
cursive
going like the bootblack
what do we feel about what cursive
going away i mean it's too bad
i'm just going away if they don't
teach in school i think i think
if they just start typing now but
i did typing in school and curse
why i did typing in eighth grade
but i i like to take her
suv in like third grade i did
typing and senior year and right almer
most ah didn't graduate because
but i think they do typing sooner
now
they should they should for sure it's
a good skill and it's important i
need to know how to do it
but i just sad i'm ok with
curse of going away i'm sad i
want them to know how to read
it the generation before us
yeah sure i mean there's something intuitive
about it though reading it right there
to be look at it like this
is a foreign language really i mean
er geez i guess g's are the
biggest difference no but you know because
if you're just printing a lowercase g
it looks like a no yeah upper
case g doesn't look like the printed
upper
case g no it doesn't it's true
it looks like a shield or something
doesn't it oh yes a shield yes
so if your name is like greg
here from the ca the word your
name is shield r e
mia healed
mini shit
ah
paul tells mike about this you know
and in the news about this okay
so the the thing that the two
most notable things are twelve there's a
few notable things rick and jules had
a terrible relationship they fought all the
time and very loudly um and eventually
rick moved out um
todd would sometimes ah he would come
home after work these guys would get
home late at night and ah todd
would fall asleep sitting up up in
the living room
um at one point jules got a
dog ah didn't really clear this with
the rest of the house she littered
with rick but not with the other
two of the guy who didn't live
there anymore or he was there this
is before yes she's still cleared everything
with
cool items is lush
um and he ah thank you so
she got this dog and i i've
mentioned this dog before you guys this
is a dog that would bite you
if you talk baby talk to it
oh wow what a specific problem yes
and ah this dog also was left
alone because they would go out to
work and i would go out to
work and the dog was just in
the house by its
self and would shit all over the
cheese and i would have to come
home and clean it up because i
was the only one there that sucks
but yeah she talks socked it so
i don't have lived with people who
would have just let it be on
the ground really i have at least
one yeah yeah i'm
not sure and you know i bet
this yeah it's such a risky game
this roommate roundup it is
i have one that i think we've
done that who i i barely know
it all i only lived it was
a stranger when i moved in with
him and i um he but i
also like he kind of knows what
i'm up to these days oh yes
you don't want to shade that was
it i don't know if jewels is
the thing this jewels was a lovely
person she was a dear friend of
mine and i
hope she's doing well yeah she talks
about that dog though should it take
about that dog that was a weird
decision um but the dog's name was
mrs beastly oh that's cute is there
can i ask a question is there
any human being named fido
um i'll google yeah i believe that
there is and it's fido dido who
can die ten years ago
fido the person you don't have that's
just it's just a dog name like
why is it exclusively for dogs why
is fido where did even come from
so good question you know like why
why did dogs have a lock on
fido i'd like to be about righto
the name fido comes from the latin
meaning to trust or confide in in
short i am faith
hateful not surprisingly abraham lincoln named his
dog fido around five years before he
became president perhaps surprising from bouts of
depression pets often pulled him from anguish
that's just something i know my jesus
hold him from anguish what a weird
third sentence on the wikipedia entry for
fido it's suddenly getting depression it's from
fit bark dot com do we have
to drag my depression into everything leave
me out of it
so a surprisingly he named paul fight
out five years before becoming president in
your reminiscence than paul doesn't make sense
yeah
ah what's his name moved out and
then yes then you add two roommates
but was not replaced oh no rick
was replaying recording but that's that's an
entirely new therein hangs a tale for
another time ya gotta lotta lotta leave
them wanting more yeah yeah yeah mine's
gonna be anticlimactic
so i can i go next is
it corruption known yes i check my
second roommate
mine i've talked about before it's the
two guys that the iab parties and
the hey i don't know where i
belong here in the tracks like classic
got about a vlogger the troll was
it he was in the garbage he
was upset that that my one roommate
took the the magazine salesman girl into
his bedroom to have sex with her
because he kind of liked her and
so he went inside the cupboard where
we kept the trash can and said
i'll just be in here because i
belong here with the trash and
and he said not as a jury
yeah he was here and he he
was not pulled from his anguish by
oh and wait so i have parties
guy was the one who was bone
in his crush bone it away yeah
and because he was the cool one
and and the other guy felt it
was the cool one yeah i know
but i artist for a while we
shared airtime me and the me the
trash guy shared a room where we
both trust we both slept on like
couch cushions on the ground this was
after you you were allowed
yeah got through the missions got rid
of the pullout couch so i just
have the i have a cushions and
we both were like on separate ends
of the room i'm like so much
cushion rose guy was like weird like
that i feel like so many guys
i know are like slip on the
floor or not really are they did
you know well it's when i put
up yeah when i was in the
military yeah they read about it
when i was in the military it
was like you know i got used
to sleeping on the cold ground you
know yeah when i forget you here
oh here you know yeah when i
was in prison i slept on thin
cot and ah so i can only
be comfortable that way yeah um it
is it is wild hell much squalor
that young men put up with
want to be gross i owe nobody
wants to i just didn't know where
i could get a bed it was
one of those things don't know your
friends have one came back no that's
the thing like ask one person you
could have told me i would have
been oh okay really i could just
ask what all you want but i
mean i had it in that place
i had a mattress on the floor
in my bedroom well yeah i mean
no i had
add a bed frame until they get
girlfriend and the girlfriend until the early
two thousands but yeah that's the thing
is i was living on literally seventy
five dollars a week and i would
write i helped many guys get into
bed frames yeah i did hey we
can ah we can't be living like
this huh
okay but what about my roommates so
by the way it is by the
way by the way they i got
i do have to put a capper
on the end of the story of
when when did our roommate reminiscence hand
at the end of the semester this
is my second this is what where
i lived for my second semester and
by the way when my first room
may moved out ah
i could not afford the apartment and
so the only person in our school
who's still needed a roommate was this
girl stacey
levin and i told my parents and
we ah we were not together or
had any kind of romantic relationship it
was just what her mom did have
it going on
of course she was gorgeous
letting go in and i said to
my parents i said to my parents
hey the only roommate i can get
is this girl stacey and they said
well we don't want you living with
a woman so we'll just sinful will
pay the extra rent for the month
until you can find a different roommate
so i lived alone um
on christmas and to cheer myself up
i've got a big christmas tree and
the needles were all over the floor
when i moved out and i just
left him there and lost my entire
deposit anyway eating just because of pine
needles on the floor yeah oh my
god damn landlords get me for the
shipment i had so hard to get
out to convert yeah that was cracked
i didn't notice and i think they
charged me hundreds of dollars and i
was i tried to find it and
they got bitchy i was like this
is so stupid you yeah you anyways
so just gone so my rooney's is
just gone the trash guy and i
parties guy we ended my second semester
of college ah as friends and ah
but ah
then i moved back home for the
summer and we didn't need to be
roommates anymore so there was no drama
there now well i'm glad that's that's
a night that stood way i wish
all roommate reminiscences would end yeah now
cascara gonna ask you this about the
the pullout couch you kept the cushions
did you just throw away the couch
itself i think i think we
just like i left it out on
the street or something like that and
i to be honest i don't know
where the cushions were because i did
not keep those cushions i don't know
where those cushions were that i slept
on in these are different cushions these
couch cushions and i feel like it
was one of my new roommates like
when i was casting about like hey
what what place do
we have they're like well we have
this couch we just put the cushions
down on the floor if you want
to sleep on those for the bed
yeah okay and did your legs go
off the end i know i think
i think we like had enough cushions
that they didn't and did you say
poaching still all night no i used
i used to sleep i used
sleep really well and don't remember having
any trouble and actually you know i
had i had like i was dating
and they came over and like stay
they weren't happy about it scott they
weren't me
like a roommate was very quiet in
my right was sitting on his couch
cushions what we blinked on my couch
cushions use your data limit land together
so sometimes sometimes we would like i
would just be in the living room
with her if she were staying over
and then sometimes i remember like us
all three sleeping in the same room
so i don't know like he'd get
home after yeah i mean i get
it but it's not cool no no
it's not right yeah not great think
those times are aimed do what you
gotta do
that's being super poor i was to
do you do it you go yeah
yea fuck on the couch cushions um
okay so my i moved out of
the dorms because i got some friends
from my improv classes that i had
been doing since i was a senior
in college into my freshman year and
they hadn't one of them mary beth
had an apartment with it was
three bedroom she was living in and
her two roommates are moving out and
so she asked if me and my
friend who you know from comedy bang
bang as molly power who played ah
vampire or something yeah vampire yeah or
yeah ikea law i believe it was
yeah that's right i forgot about
that and we moved in together it
was very exciting because we were all
good friends and um i was it
was just the best time ever and
that last we had the best parties
there we had a huge apartment that
was like in boys town
you into this party parties i did
have parties all the time and we
would post on the improv message board
or having a party and everyone can
come and then it would just be
everyone who goes to show up oh
sure everyone everyone who does improv kinda
i don't remember income and their roberts
would combine you know you
yeah another baby daddy would have
we had em all everyone was
and it was always great um and
that lasted for a year and then
she molly moved out and my new
best friend candy moved in and that
was very fun as well do you
mean louie we are we can't talk
about candy
is your next room and you're right
you're right
right so that's where it ends so
so molly was your it was just
you that molly mary beth okay mary
tables and second city and it was
a little bit older than us few
years older and um so she was
like the one who kind of like
knew how to be an adult and
we learned a lot she had a
real job
and we are both in college so
ah it was just a blast you
know just smoking duties and sitting on
the couch yeah yeah well i should
say that my job at that time
of those roommates i worked at a
store called in general which was a
sort of modern take i swear to
god i screw up sir
third
it was a modern take on a
general store which meant that they sold
um like housewares ups there was it
was two levels they had housewares upstairs
like usually is ah shit like downstairs
downstairs was the stuff that brought people
into the store was like fun stuff
that brought people ah like what
like this little fuckin novelties and toys
and currently like funny calendars and shit
like that i like this that was
that was no place where i was
sitting on the steps and a woman
was scared of the inflatable snake that
was hanging on the side of the
steps and i when i wiggled it
at shoe
and you ruined her life ruined her
life and to this day i don't
know why i did that was done
that way she's so scared just she
was hard as york city
just about yeah yeah when i it
was a weird compulsion that i have
never felt before or since i love
it wow but that makes you feel
guilty when you do spend like that
oh it's a horrible horrible you've never
played it yeah well i think my
mind i was like
come on this isn't you know it's
not a real snake come on yeah
i'm just scared but sometimes you're just
not expecting something to move and that
scary oh no but she was she
was scared of it before i did
anything it was like this inflatable thing
it was clearly fake hanging on the
side of the steps and and um
that's she like recoil from it like
when she was on
the floor and her friends said she's
very afraid of snakes i oh i
don't buy i don't buy that you
can't be a cartoon snake i have
to say to have you can if
it's suddenly move comes to life when
your passengers see i told you guys
this before but the comedy bang bang
tv show we had one of the
executives was
so afraid of snakes that we could
not write snakes into the show no
we were not allowed because they said
cheek she won't be able to watch
the episode so she won't be able
to approve the episode if there's a
snake oh my she's so and it
hypnotized any comedy sketch that had a
snake so so at one point just
to be
to be funny or whatever we wrote
one sketch that that went up the
chain of like it was attack of
the snakes and he was just like
ten pages of snakes jumping out all
the time and were like hey this
is this is the sketch we're really
interested in doing next and it came
back like they're like we can't even
show this to her the italy there's
no way
a you can ever do this back
of this and we're like what that's
it's really funny though don't you think
maybe i'm very intrigued did you try
to write it as a funny sketch
i don't actually try to make it
a rarely adjust it was purely just
nature's others and it comes out exactly
where like it's really funny though don't
think they didn't even read it they
just make me yeah we can
can't know of this hobble but but
if you see a snake in the
first couple of years it's because we
snuck one past and they were like
okay we'll give you one we'll give
you why did you need to have
one because you wanted to have one
because of this to prove everyone's while
there'd be a skit i remember there
being a sketch where someone was standing
in a waiting pool
with like a bunch of snakes garter
snakes thing there's yeah yeah you know
snakes are good coffee i think it's
time to do a three cheer honestly
well we got to take a break
i know yeah so we'll be right
back
okay however you have everyone we're back
henry
actually this reminds me of one of
my favorite ah cameos that i've seen
ryan cabrera the singer who would sing
the song he if he didn't actually
sim sneezing on the way down something
like that anyway he has this cameo
where he he like um is like
saying happy birthday and he's like so
out of breath
and i don't know why
hey hey amanda this was a heavy
orte and because it was yeah happy
birthday hey saber teva
did he just plain believe it's your
birthday
was it this was a cameo that
he was doing yeah time for three
chirp was a long episode friends this
episode is so i mean this um
game is called lyrical synonyms it was
submitted by act underscore oh that's rich
whoa there
oh one player recites the lyrics of
a song using as many synonyms as
possible the other two try to guess
the song for example the lemon example
the lot of us together resided an
amber underwater vessel
god it would yellow submarine yes ok
so we all live in a yellow
submarine now we can begin do we
have to now let's decide doing justin
the look on their lyrics i was
gonna say we should be able to
google the lyrics because yeah i was
gonna say do it do we have
to get the entire lyric or just
the song title we have to decipher
what i think being said yeah
yeah we have to decipher what song
the other person is reading the lyrics
to yeah we also deciphered the title
yeah because i know we have to
get the title but we also have
to decide for the entire lyric yeah
okay okay ooh why we well like
i said already what you would to
say for it if you know the
song you'd be able to go with
this
let's see what happens let's see what
happens that's the way the best features
start is let's see what happens okay
and maybe also the worst ones okay
ah okay i could go okay okay
one such as i
this did not intend
to bring about feelings of dismay in
you um and one such as i
certainly never thought i didn't mean to
turn you on no didn't certainly never
thought manta her
or two but i'm afraid to let
you go no i never dare you
whatever
i want such as i certainly never
meant for any feelings of discomfort ah
to be a i don't want to
make you cry for ny you've got
to guess the song title you can't
just make you cry that's not assault
all that i desired was
in a singular instance to visualize and
to to to to visualize you shortly
and defying
all i desired was to visualize you
chortling and guffawing inside the
inside the the the the v v
v v v e shirts eggplant colored
ah weather oh hey i just wow
i only wanna see laugh and the
purple rain huh
a huh
right
a good yeah my turn okay
okay this is hard yeah for sure
okay
ah are and start acting it before
a word came out she's like a
very sincere and and did a hand
gesture like ah come into
your existence
it is a lack of
looking
in the past
including during slumber
you sleep us
us
i see you being the best the
most perfect version of yourself
spin your behind
on the woman who encompasses earth all
people desire to
damn but all people desire shooting down
to the ground all people desire to
everyone
everyone wants everyone wants at something no
not everyone all people everyone everybody wants
to rule the world yeah yeah um
to to ya
a did you take a ding ding
ding ding oh thanks you think of
the dennis miller show ah but you
always think of the dennis miller show
what does it remind me of that
guy
okay you're right
acting you don't stop i'm trying to
eat your name's san da the everyday
the noisy new wo ni oh so
let me open header
we're writing oh yes go oh life
was shopping in the human mall keep
going alright
here is mine ok
pardon
have you observed excuse me while i
kiss this pardon me boy is that
the chattanooga choo-choo yes i my synonym
for pardon was martin
excuse me
pardon
are you able to observe
now that the sun has risen ah
excuse me
can you see the object of learning
the object of our
admiration allegiance
when
back when the sun had just gone
down
so
is sana synonym fur it's
it's kind of like big fat lines
it's got ah strong twinkly things stars
stars big fat lines stars and stripes
oh say can you see by the
dawn's early light that's correct our spangled
nash your favorite oh the only song
that matters yeah this is um what's
it called
when it's free what
public domain yeah i did a public
domain song just in case oh god
that's smart yeah smart looking out for
us guys we didn't want to be
shutdown this week these synonyms they're gonna
know that we're seeing a song that
is copy written copy or honor they
describe the song using synonyms in an
effort to subvert the payment policy
well guys i was fun i enjoyed
that was fun when i didn't have
fun and i like i enjoyed the
challenge i enjoyed spending time with you
on the last three episode of twenty
twenty one wow can you believe it
i actually can't believe that twenty twenty
one is over i actually find that
disgusting
if you find a second meeting yeah
it's disgusting this was a great year
i'm sorry to see it go
i can only imagine next year is
gonna be even better
i have a question i've a question
yeah should meeting each other briefly should
we not remember that and it should
it not pop into our brains ever
ah with ah the a m hours
of scott i think i know what
you're saying you're saying should oh way
way and see for god ah
bra to ma o and show o
a and b for god ah and
a o
whoa
da da
i so fun to do over zoom
and so somebody got home it was
a fun game in itself love y'all
we yeah we thank you for listening
to you in twenty twenty two and
remember you can you can listen to
these episodes ad-free at stitcher premium and
also cvb world dot com you can
check out our mer
merch at pod swag and you can
follow us on instagram three m usa
twitter three m usa and write to
us at three m usa at gc
dot com you can go fuck yourselves
if you want you can join an
option it's an option it offers yeah
we're not saying you should do that
we're saying you can you good
good
and maybe someday hey
uh